منظمات اوميه تدعو طالبان لتراجع عن
قرارات منع النساء من العمل والتعليب
والمشاركه في الحياه العامه
سفاره الانذار تدوي في بعض مناطق اوكرانيا
وانفجارته
اليمين القانونيه اليوم واحزاب اليمين
تطالب بهامش اكبر للجيش في الضفه الغربيه
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير واهلا بكم
من العربيه
كما حب وزراء وخارجيه دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي والولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
حكومه طالبان على الغاء قرارها بمنع
الموظفات من العمل في منظمات الاغاثه وقال
وزراء والخارجيه في بيان لهم ان قرار
طالبان المتهور والخطير باستبعاد النساء
من العمل في المنظمات غير الحكوميه
الوطنيه والدوليه يعرض الملايين من
الافران الذين يعتبدون على المساعدات
الانسانيه الى الخطا
وانت طيبه
بان عناصر تابعه للاستخبارات والحرس
الثوري الايراني الالكترونيه
توسع تحرك من اطلقته مجموعه من النواب
الالمان قبل بضعه اسابيع برعايه السجناء
السياسيين في ايران
العربيه
يريدون القيامه
سياسيين في ايران في الايام الماضيه
في الايام الماضيه
لوالدين ايرانيين يشرحون الرعايه السياسيه
تعني الاهتمام بقضيه السجناء والتعامل مع
المحاكمات الصواريه التي يتعرضون لها في
ايران
لنظام الايراني
وقد لاحظنا في الايام الماضيه ان الضغوط
على ايران تحدث تفارقا وهي غالبا تساعد
منصور
دي تقول الحكومه انه قرار يتخذ داخل
الاتحاد الاوروبي
هو الاهم والاكثر رمزيه ولكن اعتقد انه
يجب اتباعه بعقوبات اضافيه ضد من هم في
السلطه في ايران واعتقد ان الخطوه التاليه
يجب ان تستهدف النواب الايرانيين المئتين
227 ومن له يدوم في اعدام المتظاهرين من
قضاه ومددعين وغيرهم وهذا يبعث برساله
واضحه اننا لن نتغاضى عن جرائم ضد حقوق
الانسان
سنه
يؤكد النائب الاشتراك ان هدفها تقويه موقف
وزيره الخارجيه التي تتحدث منذ بدايه
التظاهرات عن مساء اوروبيه لاضافه الحارس
السوري للائحه الارهاب هذا التحرك الذي
يشهده البرلمان الالماني وصل صده الى
برلمانات اوروبيه اخرى في فرنسا وبريطانيا
والسويد وغيرها من الدول التي يتواصلوا
نوابها مع نواب الالمان لمعرفه كيفيه
رعايه سجناء في ايران العربيه
اعلنت السلطات الاوكرانيه حاله التاهب من
القارات الجويه في بعض مناطق اوكرانيا
اليوم في مناطق نيكولايبروليه
على الرئيس الاوكرانيا الافراج عن نحو
الفن 1450 اسيرا اوكرانيا منذ بدء الحرب
الروسيه على بلاده قال الرئيس الامريكي
يمثل اولويه بنسبه ليوكرانيا
يسير جنبا الى جنز مع هدف اخر الا وهو
اطلاق سراح جميع المحتجزين في السجون
الروسيه وكذلك جميع الذين تم ترحيلهم قصرا
من اراضينا ومنذ الرابع والعشرين فبراير
تمكن فريقنا من اطلاق سراح
1456 شخصا من اسرانا في روسيا
تعملوا الولايات المتحده على منعيران من
مساعده روسيا في حرب اوكرانيا وتقول صحيفه
نيو تايمز
العقوبات بشكل خاص للوصول الى نتائج
ايجابيه ربما يكون الامر صعب جدا على
واشنطن كما جاء في هذا التقرير
الولايات المتحده تبحث عن اساليب لمواجهه
انتاج ايران للمسيرات وذلك من خلال
العقوبات ومنع التصدير والتحدث الى
الشركات التي تستعمل ايران قطاعها في
الانتاج هذا التصريح يدل اولا على ان
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها لن يتمكنوا من
فرض حصار بالقوه يمنع ايران من مساعده
روسيا في حرب اوكرانيا
لكنها لم تمنع استمرار ايران في انتاج
مسيرات الكثير من هذه التكنولوجيا والقطاع
استعمالها مزدوج ومن المستحيل منعه ايران
من الحصول عليها
التحدي الاكبر الذي تواجه الولايات
المتحده هو ان صناعه المسيرات الايرانيه
تستعمل قطعا متوفره في الاسواق العالميه
لوضعها على محركات المسيره وغالبيه القطاع
من اشباه الموصلات والمحركات الصغيره
متوفره للهواه وتمكن الايرانيون من
تحويلها الى اسلحه
عصبه من المستحيل تقريبا منع موده تجاريه
من الوصول الى يد الطرف الذي لا ترغب به
المره الاولى التي تم فيها الحديث عن هذه
المشكله كان في تقرير لمؤسسه امريكيه
بدايه الخريف الماضي وقالت ان القطاع
تستوردها ايران من النمسا والمانيا
وبريطانيا والولايات المتحده
من الاستيراد من الاسواق الغربيه لكن
التحدي الاكبر يعود الى اسواق الصين ربما
لا تستطيع الولايات المتحده ايران من
تصنيع المسيارات والصواريخ وسيكون على
واشنطن وحلفائها تعزيز المساعدات العسكريه
لاوكرانيا خصوصا المضادات الجويه وهي تفعل
الكثير من ذلك الان نجم
الدولار
اربعه الاف دولار اوكرانيا تحتاج الى
اعتاد للدفاع عن بنيتها التحتيه والمدنيين
خصوصا الاسلحه قصيره المدى والاقل تماما
هناك اساليب كثيره في لعبه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لمساعدته اوكرانيا لكن
المشكله لدى واشنطن هو ان ايران اخذت جانب
روسيا وسيكون من المستحيل على طهران ان
تغير موقفه في الغنم العربيه واشنطن
وزير الخارج من الولايات المتحده موسكو
عبر القنوات الدوبلوماسيه انها لا تعتزم
رساله خبراء الى اوكرانيا لاداره منظومات
للدفاع التي سيتم استخدامها في ساحه
المعركه
السعودي
المتعلقه بالازمه الاخرانيه
كافه الجهود الدوليه الى حل الازمه
الاوكرانيه سياسيه
تتابعون ايضا في هذه النشره ولكن بعد ذلك
الغنوشي امام القضاء التونسي اليوم بسبب
جهاز النهضه السري
اهلا بكم من جديد همم عفوا من المقرر ان
تؤدي الحكومه الاسرائيليه برئاسه اليمين
اليوم امام الكنيسه
وتتمنى الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده افكار
اليمين المتطرف الى جانب تشديد السيطره
على القدس المحتله وتوسيع الاستيطان
ومحاربه ايران وتطالب واحزاب اليمين
المتطرفات بمنح الجيش هامش تحرك اكبر في
الضفه الغربيه
[تصفيق]
الناشئه وقعت في قبضه متطرفين يحملون
ايديولوجيات عنصريه يقولوا الاسرائيليون
يا هوبا واضحه خاصه على الصعيد الامني بعد
منحه سلطات الواسعه لشركيه
وتمر بني كبير
هذه الكتله النبي المتطرفه بوجوده داخل
ائتلاف الحاكم من شانها ان اا تساهم في
ازدياد من
الانقسام داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي هذه
الكتله حقيقه وان كانت تتمسح بالصهيونيه
هي ليست كذلك لا تؤمن بالقيم التي اسست
عليها الحركه الصهيونيه
مساواه بين الرجل والمراه بين المواطنين
بين مكونات الشعب داخل اسرائيل
على العنف والارهاب سيتولى منصبه وزير
الامن القومي وسيمنح السيطره المباشره على
حارس الحدود بحيث يكون قادرا على التاثير
على التعليمات للقوات في الميدان ويرغب
بنجير بتوفير الحصانه للجنود والشرطه
الاسرائيليه لاطلاق النار والذي اعتبره
الفلسطينيون اعطاء الجنود تصريحا غير
محدودا للقتل
لا شك في انه اسرائيل اليوم امام مواقع
غريب وغير مضبوط حيث انه مجموعه من
المتطرفين الذين لم يخدموا بالجيش انا
الجيش حقيقه لم يتقبلهم بسبب ماضيهم
المشاهب في صباهم يريدون التحكم في
المؤسسه العسكريه واملائه جدتهم المتطرفه
والعنصريه على على الجيش وقوى الامن
الدينيه سيتولى منصب وزيرا في وزاره الامن
وسيطر على الاداره المدنيه وسيكون تعزيز
وتوسيع الاستيطان وتهجير مزيدا من العرب
من اولوياته
على ما يبدو حكومه نتنياهو الناشئه ستؤدي
الى فوض داخليه وتاكلي دعم الناخبين
العلمانيين لحزب اليكود اضافه لتفجير
الوضع الميداني في الضفه الغربيه المحتله
وافسادهم طبقه من علاقات بين اسرائيل
والسلطه الفلسطينيه لان كل غاصي من القدس
العربيه
حضر الوزير
الايرانيين والبوافيق الدوله
فتاه الامم المتحده للدعم في ليبيا عظم
المبعوث الخاص الامم المتحده الى ليبيا
عبد الله باتيلي يعني خريطه طريق تتضمن
تشكيله حكومه جديده
رئيس تونسي قيسي سيد اي تراجع للحريات او
الحقوق في تونس منذ وصوله الى السلطه
واتهم من وصفهم بالمتباكين على حريه
التعبير بالمرتزقه
وهؤلاء
حريه التعبير
هؤلاء ليس لديهم حريه التفكير بل هم
مرتزقه هبه ب 40 مليون
وهبتها شركه
لرئاسه الحكومه في سنه 17 او 16
باسمي
اصلاح المنظومه الاعلام
وتمتع بها
عدد من من يدعونه
في وسائل الاعلام
مرتزقه
من المقرر ان يمثل رئيس حركه النهضه راشد
الغنوشي اليوم امام القضاء للتحقيق معه
فيما يعرف بقضيه الجهاز السري لحركه
النهضه
السياسيين والتجسس والتامر على امن الدوله
وكان قاضي التحقيق في محكمه اريانه
اصدارات بطاقه
الداخليه
بينها وزير الداخليه
في تونس تعتظمه سلطات تخفيض ودعم المواد
الاساسيه بنسبه تتجاوز 30% والمحروقات
بنسبه تفوق الخمسه والعشرين بالميه ضمن
ميزانيه العام المقبل 20 23
ميزانيه الدوله والضغط على النفقات
العموميه
يعمل فوزي في احدى احياء العاصمه التونسيه
في مجال المطاعم وتقديم الاكلات السريعه
منذ زياده من 30 عاما يقول ان سنه الحاليه
هي الاصعب بنسبه اليها في ظل الارتفاع
الجنوبي للاسعار المواد الاوليه
والاستهلاكيه
سواء احنا في صعوبه
2023 و20
صاحب محل انا ممكن ما كملوش
غضبوا اصحاب المهن الصغرى الاسعار
يتقاسموه معهم المواطن الذي وجد نفسه
مضطرا الى الله في وراء مواد الطاقه
والوقوف في توابير من اجل تحصيل بعض
المواد الغذائيه المفقوده من المحلات
والاسواق
الضوء انا ماشيين في التصعيد مش يزيدوا
فيه شلون اللي خلوني
الحمله حتى شيء تحطه 30 دينار وتروح وما
في مشكله
قانون الماليه
الاساسيه بنسبه تفوق الثلث وسيشهد دعم
المحروقات تراجعا بالنسبه تفوق الربوع
رفضته منظمات المجتمع المدنيه وبررته
الحكومه بالظرفيه الاقتصاديه الصعبه محليا
والوليا
هناك ارتفاع متواصل في كل المواد وفي كل
الخدمات وخاصه بارتفاع ثمن
المحروقات اكيد منها بقيه
المكونات
ترفع منها ترفع في الكلفه وبالتالي هذا
يازم الوضع شرائح كثيره من المجتمع كنا
نخشى عن الشرائح الضعيفه اليوم حتى شرائح
المتوسطه اصبح مهندده كذلك
وتعمل تونس على تحقيق نسبه نمو في حدود
واحد فاصل ثمانيه بالمئه سنه القادمه عبر
تفعيلي عدد من الاصلاحات الاقتصاديه
والحصول على قرض مالي جديد من صندوق النقد
الدولي
بين نظرتي مواد الطاقه والمواد
الاستهلاكيه وغلاء اسعارها وشح الموارد
الماليه للدوله تتواصلوا معاناه التونسيين
الذين تراجعات قدرتهم شراءيه وسطها
تحضيرات من توتر الوضع الاجتماعي وليد عبد
الله العربيه
تونس
العربيه
تشهد عدد من الجامعات الحكوميه السودانيه
احتجاجات على خلفيه زياده الرسوم التي
فرضت على الطلاب الجدد الذين قبلوا على
نفقه العامه الاحتجاجات دفعت اداره
الجامعه السودان للعلوم والتكنولوجيا الى
تعليق الدراسه بمجمع كليه الهندسه
خلف الاسوار الحرم الجامعي لبعض الجامعات
الحكوميه في السودان
ساحات تحولت للاحتجاج الذي وصل حد الدعوه
الى الاضراب تعبيرا عن الرفض لزيادات
الكبيره التي طرات على الرسوم الدراسيه
يقول الطلاب ان العام الدراسي للعام 2022
2023 هو الاغلى من حيث الاموال التي تدفع
الى خزائن الجامعات السودانيه القضيه
تاريخيه اعلان الحاجه دي حاليا الان نحن
في امام همم بدايه لتاريخ بتاع تسريع
بتاعه تعليم
ممكن نوصل لحد الاحتياجات في شعرها لقياس
الاحتياجات اصل لحد الغسل مقاطعه ادراج كل
السوبر متاحه هنعمل اتخذها عشان انضغط
ينتصر يعني الحاصل لحاجه حزينه جدا همم
يعني واثار اللي قدام ح- سيئه شديد احنا
منها شيء ممكن نكون شايفينها فبصراحه باحب
اشكر الناس اللي هو فيه معانا هنا
والاهالي اللي واقفين وصابرين همم على
الرسوم العاليه جدا وعلى انهم هم لحد الان
وقاطعينه واقفين معنا في المقاطع هذه
السودانيه وصلت في بعض منها الى 900%
زياده تعللها اداره الجامعات بالزياده
الكبيره في الخدمات ومطلوبات العمليه
التعليميه احنا بالنسبه لنا رسومات هي
الاشكاليه الكبرى تصنيف الدوله الجامعات
الحكوميه همم في الكهرباء هي مخطوطه في
الترانكي وبدفعوها 59 همم على الكيلو وات
فديها في حد ذاتها ارهقت الجامعه ارهاق
شديد ولا يمكن الامور تستقيم
الزيادات الكبيره في رسوم الجامعات مردها
لسياسات الدوله وعجزها عن الايفاء بدعم
العمليه التعليميه في المرحله الجامعيه
هذا بحسب بعض المراقبين وزاره الماليه
تعطي وزاره التعليم العالي جامعه الحكوميه
مجرد دعم ولم تلتزموا ذات الماليه بي
تعويضات العاملين ولم تلتزم بشراء السلع
والخدمات اذا فعلت التنميه ذلك كان يمكن
للجامعات الحكوميه ان تقلل معدلات الرسوم
بصوره كبيره في ظل صعوبات الاقتصاديه التي
تواجه الدوله السودانيه يبدو ان العمليه
التعليميه تواجه تحديا كبيرا حملت الطلاب
عبئا اقتصاديا مرهقا وجعل المؤسسات
التعليميه في السودان غير قادره على
الايفاء بمطلبات العمليه التعليميه بشكل
مثالي محمد عثمان العربي الخرطوم
مكتب ورئاسه الكوريه الجنوبيه الرئيس
يونسك يوم امر بتطوير منظومه الدفاع الجوي
لمواجهه اي اجسام تنتهي كل المجال الجويه
لبلاده وذلك بعد ايامنا انتهاك خمس طائرات
مسيره كوريا الشماليه للمجال الجوي لكوريا
امس في الولايات المتحده
في الوصول الى موقع التواصل الاجتماعي في
الولايات المتحده
الخاصه بهم لا تعمل
طالبان للتراجع عن قرارات منع النساء من
العمل والتعليم والمشاركه في الحياه في
العالم
سفاره الانذار تدوي في بعض مناطق اوكرانيا
في دنابر ونيكوفول وسومي
وحكومه اليهود
المزيد بعد قليل على شاشه العربيه الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]